¿Qué expresiones son equivalentes a 6 por
"v" por "w" por 1/2?
Marca todas las que apliquen.
Y bueno, aquí tengo las opciones y
vamos a marcar las correctas.
Ahora, si nos queremos acercar a esta expresión,
¿qué podríamos hacer con ésta que tenemos
aquí, con la original?
Bueno, pues esto recuerda que es lo mismo,
si nosotros cambiamos el orden de los factores
que 6, que 6 que multiplica a 1/2, ok...
6 que multiplica a 1/2, que a su vez multiplica
a "v", que a su vez multiplica a "w",
pero bueno, 6 por 1/2...
6 por 1/2 es lo mismo que 3, esto es lo mismo
que 3 que multiplica a "v",
que a su vez multiplica a "w".
Y por lo tanto, podemos ver que no es la opción
correcta porque aquí está hablando de una
suma, mientras que aquí estamos hablando
de una multiplicación y por lo tanto, no
podemos llegar a esta suma de ninguna manera.
Ahora, si nos fijamos en la siguiente opción,
ésta si es correcta, de hecho es justo lo
que llegamos, llegamos a 3 por "v" por "w"
por lo tanto voy a ponerle una palomita porque
ésta sí es una opción correcta.
Después tengo,
1 por 3 por "v" por "w" más 0, ok,
fíjate que aquí tenemos casi esto de aquí.
Si nosotros multiplicamos esta expresión
de aquí por 1, bueno pues se sigue manteniendo
exactamente igual, porque recuerda que 1 es
el neutro multiplicativo,
entonces voy a a multiplicar por 1, y entonces sigue siendo la misma expresión.
Y ahora, si a esto yo le agrego 0, si a esto
yo le sumo 0, bueno, pues date cuenta que
sigue siendo la misma expresión, cuando tenemos
algo y le sumamos nada, bueno, pues seguimos
teniendo ese mismo algo, por lo tanto, ésta
era una pregunta capciosa, lo único que nos
decían era acomodarlo de una manera que lo
viéramos exactamente igual y por lo tanto
ésta sí es una opción correcta y nos podemos
dar cuenta porque estamos multiplicando por
el neutro multiplicativo y estamos sumando
el neutro aditivo.
Ahora, tengo esta expresión de aquí abajo,
"w" por "v" por 1/2 por 6,
pero recuerda que el orden de los factores no afecta el producto, esto de aquí es exactamente lo mismo que
poner, si quiero, "w" en un primer lugar y
después se me ocurre poner "v", ok,
y después se me podría ocurrir poner a 1/2, no sé,
y después podría poner 6, al final llegamos
a la misma expresión, ¿por qué? porque
todos están multiplicando,
el orden de los factores no afecta el producto y llegamos justo a lo mismo, esta expresión de aquí
es lo mismo que esto de aquí, que es lo mismo
que esto de aquí, que es lo mismo que esto
de aquí y bueno, por lo tanto le voy a
poner una palomita.
Ya está, ya tengo estas 3 respuestas correctas,
así que vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
y para eso voy a quitar este ejercicio de aquí y
voy a borrar la pantalla...
déjame borrar la pantalla y ahora
voy a poner el otro ejercicio.
Muy bien, aquí tengo mi otro ejercicio y dice,
¿qué expresiones son equivalentes a 3 que
multiplica a "4h" más "2k"?
Marca todas las que apliquen y aquí tengo
cuatro opciones.
Entonces lo primero que se me ocurre es multiplicar
este 3 por este 4 y este 3 por este "2k",
distribuyendo el 3 y me va a quedar lo siguiente.
Esto es lo mismo que, "12h",
"12h" porque 3 por 4 es 12, más 3 por 2 es 6,
me quedaría "6k"...
"6k"...
Y bueno, si te das cuenta, lo primero que podemos ver
es que esta respuesta es exactamente
lo mismo que esto que tenemos aquí
y por lo tanto ésta si está en nuestras
respuestas correctas.
Por lo tanto le voy a poner una palomita,
ahora vamos a fijarnos en éstas otras que
tenemos por acá...
déjame fijarme primero en ésta,
¿qué te parece si nosotros distribuimos
este 2 multiplicando al "h" y multiplicando al "k"?
¿a qué llegaríamos?
Pues 2 por "6h", esto es lo mismo que,
12 veces "h", ok, y 2 por "3k" esto es lo mismo
que 6 veces "k", 6 veces "k".
Y si te das cuenta, ¡oh!, es justo lo mismo
que tenemos aquí, por lo tanto, ésta también
es una respuesta correcta.
Ok, entonces déjame ponerle con el mismo
color una... una palomita, de lujo.
Ahora fijémonos en ésta de aquí.
Yo tengo a 3 que multiplica a "4k" más "2h"
y si multiplico éste por éste y éste por éste,
¿a qué voy a llegar?
Bueno, 3 por 4 es lo mismo que 12,
12 veces"k" y después tengo 3 por "2h",
lo cual es 6 veces "h".
Y aquí, aquí llegamos a que no es lo mismo,
si te das cuenta, esta expresión es 12 veces "k"
más 6 veces "h", cuando realmente tengo
12 veces "h" más 6 veces "k", por lo tanto,
ésta no es una de mis respuestas
correctas, la voy a tachar
y ahora me voy a fijar en esta expresión que tengo aquí abajo. 3 que multiplica a "2k" más "4h",
¿y qué me quedaría si yo multiplico este 3 por éste
de aquí y este 3 por éste de aquí?
Bueno, pues me va a quedar lo mismo que 3
por 2 es 6 veces "k", ok,
y después tengo a 3 por 4 es 12 veces "h", que si te das cuenta, es justo lo mismo de acá,
si aplicamos la conmutatividad en la suma, 12 veces "h" más 6 veces "k", es lo mismo que 6 veces "k" más
12 veces "h" y por lo tanto, éste también
tiene una pequeña paloma, de lujo.
Entonces ya tenemos la respuesta correcta,
como están muy sencillos, déjame hacer otro
par más de ejercicios.
Vamos a hacer el siguiente,
déjame quitar este ejercicio de aquí y voy
a hacer el siguiente ejercicio.
Vamos a traer el siguiente problema que es
éste que tengo aquí y vamos a ver qué me dice.
Llena los espacios en blanco para crear una expresión equivalente a 6 que multiplica a "3v" más "w", ok,
pues que te parece si lo primero que se me ocurre es que podemos distribuir este 6...
Oh, espera, déjame cambiar de herramienta...
Voy a distribuir este 6 multiplicando
a este "3v" y después voy a tomarme este 6 multiplicando a este "w".
Y por lo tanto, ¿qué es lo que me va a quedar?
Bueno, pues esto es lo mismo que, 6 por 3 es 18,
18 veces "v" y a esto le voy a sumar
6 por "w" lo cual es más 6 veces "w".
Por lo tanto, si llenamos los espacios me
va a quedar 18 veces...
aquí voy a poner un 18, 18 veces "v" más
6 veces "w", por lo tanto este espacio en
blanco lo voy a llenar con un 6.
Y ya está, aquí tenemos la respuesta de
este otro problema, así que, hagamos uno más.
Voy a traer ahora, a este problema que tengo
aquí y vamos a ver qué me dice.
¿La expresión 3 que multiplica a "2f" más "g" más 4 es equivalente a 6 veces "f" más 3 veces "g" más 12?
Bueno, pues vamos a aplicar otra vez,
nuestra propiedad distributiva,
voy a multiplicar este 3 por este "2f",
también voy a multiplicar
este 3 por esta "g" y también voy a multiplicar
a este 3 por este 4,
porque este 3 multiplica a todos los sumandos que estén adentro del paréntesis.
¿Y qué me va a quedar?
Bueno, pues esto es lo mismo que 3 por "2f",
eso es 6 veces "f", ok,
y a esto, 3 por "g", bueno, eso es lo mismo
que 3 veces "g", a esto le sumamos 3 veces "g",
y por último, tengo 3 por 4.
3 por 4 es lo mismo que 12,
entonces me queda 6 veces "f" más 3 veces "g" más 12 que es exactamente lo mismo a lo que tengo aquí,
por lo tanto ya puedo concluir que esta expresión
de aquí en efecto,
es equivalente a esta otra expresión que tengo aquí.
Entonces podemos poner, ¡sí!, si son equivalentes.
Y como si son equivalentes,
es hora de acabar este video.
Ya llegamos a la respuesta correcta.